she was on this like new age stuff but
she said
not a gin she referred to it as a demon
but we we can both see it as like the
same thing pretty much
and she was saying that like everyone
has uh
a gin for like a better words assigned
to them from birth
yes it's true i mean this is an islamic
concept
we believe everyone has a companion
with them from the jinn creation
you know so this jinn will be it's
around you know the prophet salallahu
his jinn
became a muslim why do we have
a jinn yeah why do we have that
the korean is there to as a test is
everything in life is a test and and so
the korean is there as a test as well
the korean is testing us
you know encouraging us to do but the
same way your
evil friend is testing you telling you
come to the nightclub
you know or do this or do that
your friend is a test the the point is
that we have to overcome these tests
you know and and and how do we overcome
them by by by living the correct way
as best we can according to islam just
encourage them to
to learn about islam you know learn the
basics of islam
you know learn what the beliefs are of a
muslim
maybe read the quran in an english
translation
if you if you have it and learn you know
try and learn more about islam and just
be honest with yourself
you know you're sincere and you want to
find the true religion
you know put your head on the ground
right and ask the creator to guide you
you know when you're alone in your
bedroom
late at night put your head on the floor
and ask the creator to guide you if
you're sincere
and if islam is the way accept it when
it come when it becomes clear to you
don't delay it except islam you know
don't don't lie to yourself
[Music]
give my own experience with this cause
when my mom
had gotten surgery she got part of her
liver removed
she was out of commission for a year
and the entire time like i didn't do
anything for her
i was just basically hanging out with my
girlfriend
going to parties doing drugs drinking
spending time with friends basically
ducking her and my sister
was taking care of her the entire time
now my sister
didn't say anything but like after the
fact
years later i reflected on that myself
and i was like damn like that was really
rough
you know that was really rough for me to
do that to my own mother
i'd probably be questioned about that on
the day of judgment and like
that's me being a self-reflective person
being able to see that but like if my
sister would have said
what i had told you to say like i'm sure
at that moment in time it would've hit
and welcome back to the t3m podcast we
are the realest podcast in the dunya
so if you like what you see check out
our channel our other episodes like
comment and subscribe and check out
our patreon insha allah today we're
joined with a very very special guest
brother john fontaine salam
how are you doing how are you doing bro
i need to correct you on your
introduction
what did i mess up you said that it's
the realest podcast
but young smirks my podcast is so okay
what's the name of the podcast again
young smirks young smirks
check out two the two realest podcasts
in the dungeon
how about that all right masha allah so
this is
t3m x uh young smirks masha'allah
podcast
join together to bring you the realest
episode in the dunya
subhanallah so brother john i know you
have a very very interesting uh
story to islam uh so do you mind giving
a brief introduction about yourself just
so the viewers and audience know
um who their realest brother in the
dunya is masha'allah
mashallah my name is john fontaine i'm
from the uk
i'm from manchester um i've been a
muslim for about 11 years
i found islam when i was in africa
and yeah since then i've been doing dawa
um
trying to help education in africa and
trying to do a lot of
charity and our work in africa um
also researching for my book
about jesus and the injil about the
islamic perspective
of revelation and how we can kind of
give darwin to christians
um yeah that's it really
um i've got the young simonix podcast
where i interviewed different shirts
about different topics
so yeah i'm currently living in turkey i
was living in uganda and kuwait
so i traveled quite a lot i've been to
over 70 countries
a lot of them many different times as
well so
i'd kind of travel around teaching the
basics of dawah i'm not a shaykh
but i teach the basics of dawah and
the basics of islam to try to help
muslims just understand the basics
basically
you know shakes get bored with doing
you know i i don't mind teaching people
the basics of islam and getting people
to you know a good good level of islam
inshallah
inshallah may allah reward you for that
beautiful work masha allah so
uh you mentioned you reverted you've
been a muslim for 11 years you said
yeah subhanallah so what was your
perception of islam beforehand
and what was your life like before islam
and how did you end up coming to islam
um yeah i've said this story many times
but um yeah i was scared i was scared of
islam
in the beginning you know i thought it
was you know
all terrorists and i didn't really know
much about islam
being from england we didn't really grow
up with many muslims
um but then the area where i used to
live
there was a lot of africans came and
lived in the area about
15 years ago and this is when i got
introduced to
brothers from nigeria sierra leone
they were muslim by name they were not
really practicing islam but they were
they were
you know minimally muslim
if you like you know the muslim by name
some of them maybe fasted ramadan etc
but no one really prayed
um they were not really good guys uh we
was doing
you know things that are not really uh
permissible um and this kind of led me
to start doing business with them
i started to travel to africa travel to
sierra leone
and this is where i came into contact
with muslims
as i heard the adam for the first time
you know i started to
get familiar with muslims and it's the
first time i actually seen
black muslims i was actually shocked you
know because i thought islam was more
for like arabs and pakistanis
um and i was i was familiar with
african people but i didn't i didn't
really associate them with islam
so so actually traveling to africa um
you know connected that association and
it kind of made islam more palatable to
me
because i was familiar with africa and
africans
and and i could accept islam from them
you know because
i was familiar with them um whereas you
know
asian pakistani arab it was difficult to
kind of accept a religion from
you know these people who i was not
really i didn't really know much about
them you know it's a
big cultural difference to what i was
used to so um yeah so
traveling in africa and working in
africa
and this kind of led me to start looking
into islam
and eventually accepting islam
so yeah oh my shot allah and you still
do
work in africa today i know you have a
playlist on the youtube channel about
your work there
yeah so i um i went back to africa after
a few
years um when i came to islam i found
out
shortly after that i had a brain tumor
um
so i i had to stay in the uk for
for a couple years um i recovered from
that alhamdulillah had a
operation and the brain tumor was
removed
and then after that i wanted to travel
back to sierra leone
specifically sierra leone in west africa
um to try to help you know because it's
it is really one of the poorest
countries
in the world um even in africa sierra
leone is really really
one of the most difficult places in the
world so i wanted to kind of go there
uh with islamic eyes you know last time
i was going to sie leon to try to make
money
and try to you know
[Music]
with not good intentions and then now i
was going back to sierra leone
and with with good intentions to try to
to help
and and try to help islam basically yeah
masha'allah and that's what led me back
[Music]
may allah bless them and grant them you
know proper guidance and proper islam i
mean
for your work so subhanallah
you've been on the dao scene for for
quite some time then masha'allah
yeah alhamdulillah so you being in the
uk obviously you know you know speaker's
corner
hyde park um do you have any particular
stances on hyde park because i know a
few people say
a few different things like i remember
zoro's mentioned
that he doesn't go there for very
specific reasons because
uh some in some cases just argumentation
and all that so
what what are your thoughts on the dawah
scene in general um
in the the thing is uh a lot of muslims
who don't live in the uk
they think that there's a lot of dawah
happening in the uk
is that the perception you guys get yeah
yeah you know people outside of uk think
oh you know there's so much doubt
happening in england
in in reality there's very little dollar
going on in england
you know it's just this kind of inflated
perception online
you know with um different dowel
organizations
um and and obviously hyde park
um you know but the reality is most
people in the uk
most white english people have never
heard the truth about islam
you know there's very little that were
really happening
and that's just my honest opinion really
looking at it from
my perspective knowing that my my
extended family members
and and friends of family they've never
heard about islam you know so
but muslims kind of think that these
that they
that the job is being taken care of that
dawa is is really strong in the uk
it may be stronger than other parts of
the world but in reality it's still not
not enough when it comes to hyde park
i've been there a few times
[Music]
you know um i think one of the the
problems with
hyde park is the cameras you know the
cameras
being around everything being filmed um
you know this can have a problem with
with people's intentions it can also
have a problem
because people who are not qualified or
if they
if they are teaching the wrong type of
islam
you know there's a lot of mistakes
happening the videos are never edited
you know so this is this is one of the
one of the problems really
a lot of the times a lot of the videos
you see they make big mistakes
um you know in in islamic uh from an
islamic perspective you know in the way
that they um
not just in the manners but also in the
the knowledge that they're
supposedly conveying and sometimes
there's lots of mistakes
in what people are saying and it's
difficult when you've got non-muslims
and
and other people filming you because you
don't have
uh the power to edit that that
particular video
yeah so you know i think it is it's
that's quite dangerous really
yeah and that could that be can be quite
dangerous yeah it's kind of like
yeah see how that'd be an issue because
with when i started practicing
um islam i the first thing i did was
watch hyde park videos and
a part a part of it was just because how
entertaining it was
and i feel like a lot of people just
love how people are basically debating
are you going at each other people are
getting destroyed you know people love
looking up things like
david wood gets destroyed or been
shapiro destroys uh
college students and like all this stuff
and it's it's this um
this theme that's been going on and i
feel like that fuels
um a not so great part of of dabble or
not
so great way of giving dawah so i can
definitely see how it would be
an issue yeah don't get me wrong i find
it very entertaining
no it's it's it's fun it's funny to
watch is
entertaining but
is that the correct way to give darwin
would you would you recommend that video
to your own mother
to your grandmother who's who's not a
muslim you know would you recommend it
to someone you actually love
you know you probably wouldn't
um you know but yeah i mean it's even
even when you look
further back into the older videos like
dida
ahmeda and the other people who used to
debate they're very entertaining and
and may allah reward them and may allah
reward
everyone for for for trying and giving
dawah you know and and doing their best
but at the same time um you know
sometimes you have to look is that is
that the correct way is that
is that the best way is that the most
wisest way to give douwa
um maybe maybe not you know um i think
the test is if you would give it your
parents
your non-muslim parents i think that's a
good test to see
if it is uh you know a nice way of dow
or not
yeah subhan allah that's true that's
very true masha allah
um me myself a lot of what i do on on
tick tock is just um
uh reactionary or like responses
rebuttals refutations to people who
attack islam on tiktok
and for that reason alhamdulillah my
videos do pretty well but
again it's just fueling this this like
battle
um it's like this kind of like uh
intellectual jihad
and i i don't think that's that's the
best way to teach islam because it
instantly creates this dichotomy right
this is them
us versus them kind of thing whereas
islam is telling us to come to terms
and to invite people to religion of
allah and as i was actually having a
conversation with my
with my sheikh and he was telling me
that this isn't
even really tawa because if you look at
the prophets in the quran
they all give dabble by by calling for a
kind of economical
political societal change to all the
people yakomi like my people
um and nowadays i feel like a lot like
especially with what i do a lot of dawah
has been
trickled down to showing islam is a way
it's acceptable when we should be
teaching islam is the way
in the only way so i feel like that's a
fault i have in my own
uh and i feel like if we tear a dawah
towards islam being the one and only way
which a lot of brothers do with
mashaallah on the daily scene so may
allah reward them
i feel like it would um have a
significant impact if
especially if we include the wisdom and
the hikmah that you're talking about we
should have
and the method that we give dawa in in
sha allah
but speaking of which you mentioned
you're writing a book about jesus in the
injeel
right about giving dawah to christians
so can you tell us about some of your
work with that
yeah um you know before i was a muslim
when i started searching into islam um
you know i left christianity when i was
very young i must have been seven or
eight years old i knew that christianity
was not the truth
you know um and for those who've seen my
story before
um i've mentioned it a few times that
i was in church and we had to write a
song about god
and mice it was like a rap and my song
was called
jesus and god and
and the pastor he took my piece of paper
and he changed
the words to jesus is god um
and and i must have been seven or eight
years old and
and i was not happy with that you know i
was like no what
what do you mean you know that doesn't
make sense you know it's jesus and god
you know
you know obviously from that young age i
was i was on the fitrah
you know the fitra is the innate belief
that that
every human is born with to recognize
and distinguish allah from everything
else
you know everyone's born with that to ex
distinguish allah the creator from the
creation
and so from a very young age i wasn't
christian i i knew it wasn't the truth
and i used to consciously in
church like you know obviously quietly
when i'm praying i would say god i'm
praying to you not jesus
you know i would that would be like my
bismillah you know
it would be like god i'm praying to you
not jesus you know
and i would make a conscious effort to
say that in
every prayer um
and so and and and
as time went on the the more i started
to study and learn about the bible
the even less convinced i was about
about the whole religion
you know um and for me i'd left the
bible
there was no way that this bible was
from the creator
none of it you know and the more you
study it the more you realize
it's authored by human beings um there's
no
way you can attribute it to the creator
so then when i'm
searching into islam many muslims
were wrong wrongly telling me that
that muslims also believe in the bible
[Music]
do you understand they were saying well
we also believe in the bible
or we believe in the original bible and
this didn't make sense to me because
you know the bible was clearly not from
from the creator
you know and and neither the christians
were claiming it to be
directly from the creator you know the
christian concept
is that it's like a biographical account
you know the new testament is a
collection of biographies
authored by certain individuals after
the time of isla
islam as opposed to something that was
revealed to issa
if that makes sense and the same with
the old testament
you know it's something authored by
people as opposed to
uh something uh delivered to prophets
you know of course the christians and
the and the jews they claim that
these authors were inspired and but it's
not something that was directly given
to the prophets so
me having this concept and muslims wrong
wrongfully
wrongly telling me oh we believe in the
bible this kind of
led me not to be interested in islam it
would he just
islam just sounded like another sect of
christianity or mormonism
you know another group of people who
attach themselves to the bible
and they have something extra you know
which is the quran
and it didn't really interest me to be
honest until i started to research islam
properly
and realize that muslims don't believe
in the bible
you know they believe in actual books
that were
revealed to the likes of musa and issa
and dawud etc you know these were books
given to the prophets
rather than um the books authored by
people about the prophets you know so
so my book really is just kind of
discussing this you know
um looking at the islamic perspective of
revelation
um and of course that has implications
on how
you now give daoa to christians and and
how you don't give that all to
christians as well
but that's a brief kind of uh
part of it yeah yeah so where can we
find your book
where can we purchase it is it up no i
mean i've got some uh
dowel booklets that are available free
online
um they're printed in different uh
dollar centers
but i'm actually working on the big book
now um i'm not sure when it's going to
be ready
um but i'm it's something i'm working on
and
yeah i i think i personally think it's
it's quite
important it's an important
distinguished
uh distinction to make really
um because you know the speech in a lot
of muslims when they give in tawa
um again a lot of muslims especially in
the likes of hyde park and
online a lot of muslims fall into the
mistake of
that when they speak about the bible
they kind of speak with
speak about it in language that one
could assume that
muslims believe in it or that we give it
some credibility
and that can be very confusing for for
um
you know a non-muslim or even a convert
or even a muslim you know many muslims
you know have have a very wrong
understanding about the bible
you know yeah i mean what do you guys
think of the bible
you know i'll ask you guys listen my god
your story
made me remember um when i first
went into the church to get a baptism
i was my fiance my ex fiance and like
granted i grew up with a
catholicism let me say properly here
catholicism
and some christianity then i went 80
years that went the ways and i went back
to christianity
i remember this uh woman they were doing
the baptism
and the woman was like okay repeat after
me
jesus is my lord and savior and i i just
looked at it i was like god
is my lord and savior bro
she was so upset she didn't want to dunk
me in the water at all but she had to
so she dug me in and i think she held me
underneath the water for a little bit
longer
[Laughter]
yeah but it goes to show it goes to show
that like
the fitra is there it's always there and
if you start to come back to it
you start to realize like this doesn't
really make sense
yeah you know and again it took me a
while
like i didn't have what you had was like
i was having people saying that oh
muslims saying that we believe in the
bible as well
it was more so just like i saw so many
religions
i saw so many uh different books i was
just like
which one is it you know
how many versions are there of the bible
there's a lot
i heard there's a lot dude you got the
old testament you got the new testament
you got the jehovah's bible
which i think is called the uh the new
the new tech no no
new world testament or something like
that um
you got the king james yeah yeah listen
you know what happened the other day
i was playing call of duty and i meet
this guy
and i'm usually just you know when i'm
in the lobbies i get real i get deep
you know because these are last broken
people right so i like talking about
real stuff
and we were just having a talk about god
and theism
and he's uh he's an african american
brother
and contrary to everyone else he's like
he's like okay i believe in god
but i don't believe that you know all
races are equal
and i was like what are you talking
about bro and right off the bat
my radar went off and he was like i
think black people are the real jews
and i was like what and then he starts
telling me how
moses was black and jesus was black
and how the real israelites were black
you know come to find out like he's a
black hebrew israelite right
but he's telling me all these things and
and i'm just like my mind is blown like
i really believe that and then i quickly
after the call i did a little
bit of research into black hebrew
israelites you know much about them and
all
right interview yeah
um you know it is
it's possible i mean
um he would have been a darker
complexion i'm not sure how dark
um but it is a there's a hadith that
speaks about this
an authentic hadith that speaks about
islam
having light complexion of course
compared to what
you know light complexion better what
compared to the prophet sallallahu islam
you know um compared to the prophet and
all the arabs
israel islam was was lighter according
to
certain hadith um
and also uh musa musa being
being darker as well so you know
this is not an issue in islam you know
um you know that you know every tribe
a nation was sent a prophet you know
every tribe of the past was sent a
prophet of course since the time of the
prophet salallahu sallam
um this there's no more prophets you
know the prophet muhammad is the last
prophet
for everyone now well before that prior
to that
every tribal nation was sent a prophet
um
from amongst themselves you know in the
language speaking in the language of
their people
you know of course allah doesn't mention
all the prophets
um throughout time um this isn't a
hadith that mentions the 124 000
prophets
sent throughout time i think 315 of them
were
uh messengers uh actual they have a
higher status
there's there's two levels of a profit
you know there's the regular profit and
then there's a
a rasool which is a messenger uh 315 of
them were messengers
um some scholars say that the difference
is that the messengers were given
a new uh sharia
or a new revelation whereas the the
regular prophet was
preaching the previous sharia or the
previous
uh revelation although knows best is
this difference of opinion
about this there's nothing really uh you
know
you know confirmed is the difference of
opinion what the difference is and and
some scores say it's the same thing as
what
um the point is that you know that there
were there were many prophets
and messengers sent throughout time you
know to every tribe and nation
you know so they would have been the
same complexion as their tribe they
would have spoke the same language
as their tribe you know of course allah
only mentions
uh 25 or 26 mentioned in the quran
you know if you count some some scholars
count
hidden as a prophet um the witch which
was the companion of
muslim which taught musa
um so you know this this there's um
these 25 or 26 mentioned in the quran
and most of them are from the bani
israel which are mentioned in the quran
some of the four of them
uh or five of them i should say uh arabs
you know the rest of them have been in
israel you know
uh apart from the likes of no holy salam
and adam
not any israel but of course the bene
israel do accept them as prophets
um well yeah i mean it's it's very
feasible that there were prophets with
different from different
parts of the world different tribes
different colours different races et
cetera
yeah for the guy to think that or
there's a superior
he basically said black supremacy is
like legit
and the only way you could be savored by
god is
like if you're black and i was like why
wouldn't that i i clearly asked the one
question too i was like
look i understand i'm muslim myself so i
understand about this whole
there is no you know we shouldn't be
racist and all that but do you really
think god would be racist and he's like
of course and i was like what do you
mean and he's like
well god preferred the black people the
true
israelites i was like bro what are you
talking about like do you hear yourself
yeah and he's on that yeah if he's on
that then
what does he think about adam what's he
gonna say oh adam was black
and well i think this whole conception
of black is so flawed where it's like
dude most black people are brown
like real black people is like very few
and those are the ones that look burnt
i think they came out the oven and i'm
not talking bad about it i'm just saying
like look if you want to talk
about like actual black this is black
the shirt that john is wearing is black
your jacket is black
ramy's beanie is black but most black
people are actually brown
they're not black mixed yeah so i mean
it's just me
kind of like breaking it down here but i
think i think that's a very flawed
perception
yeah definitely i don't know i mean this
is this is a problem when you don't have
guidance when you don't have a
revelation from allah
your your your desires kick in right
the christians did it the the white
christians used christianity
to promote white supremacy to conquer
the world
my people specifically you know the
british people used it more than anyone
um i think the only um
nation to use it as as as widespread as
britain would probably portugal and
maybe france
you know but these these nations
portugal france
um and the british you know they used
christianity
to promote white supremacy to to promote
um you know uh you know their race
basically and then and
the the black israelites is the exact
opposite
they're doing the same thing but under
the under the uh
you know the the the black race you know
they just
same thing this is misguidance you know
um
obviously you know we do believe that
that there is
that of course um the the prophet peace
be upon him told us that
he is from the best tribe you know
from the from the best tribe that there
is different status of tribes
okay um in terms of their morals in
terms of their lineage
you know these things do matter okay but
at the same time
there were some of the prophets family
members who are kuffar
they're not muslim so their tribe did
not benefit them one bit
does that make sense you know if you the
the the
the the the point of it benefiting you
is means you have to accept islam you
have to be muslim in the first place for
these things to actually benefit you
you know so um the prophet salallahu did
have a certain
status um even from his lineage
perspective
and even isla islam you know he had a a
righteous
lineage you know his lineage came from
both
um the tribe or the lineage of dawood
and suleiman as well as
on the other side the paternal side had
the lineage of
obviously his mother maryam and also
going back to haroon
and musa you know so islam was very
you know coming from very very strong
lineage
um but again this is no
no reason to be arrogant
because who you are and it doesn't
really help you
unless you're following the guidance of
allah you know and this is the
importance of having wahi
of having revelation and being clear on
you know what is our guidance what do we
follow what makes us
the best nation you know that allah
mentions
and that we are the best nation you know
you know that you are the best nation
for the people why
it's not automatic because you command
the good
because you forbid the evil and you
believe in allah
you know that is the in order to be a
part of this best nation
it's not because you're white it's not
because you're black it's not because
you're from a particular tribe it's
because you command the good and forbid
the evil
according to the quran and the sunnah
okay not according to your own desires
okay that's the that's the point and you
believe in allah
that you know you have to believe in
allah that's the
the the core foundation and you're
basically following the guidance of the
revelation
and commanding it and forbidding the
evil you're commanding the good
you know pushing giving dawah calling to
it
advising your muslim brothers you know
uh to to do good
forbidding the evil that they do and uh
this is what makes you the best nation
you know
and that's a very powerful ayah in the
quran um
that you are the best nation for the
people the best example
to humanity that's what it means
subhanallah
why because you command the good forbid
the evil and you believe in allah
and if you look at many ayah in the
quran subhanallah where
um allah refutes the the previous
nations of the yahuwah and the sarah
you know it's because they didn't
command the good and forbid the evil
they just allowed people to go on doing
what they want to do
and that's where the society goes into
decline
and then you lose all your morals you
know that's when you start following
your desires you know so
so yeah so do you think that that's what
kind of
uh bred this whole arab superiority
thing
it's always been there is is it's just
something that
has always been there and it will not be
there
it's always going to be there you're
always going to have
if you've not got white people doing it
to black people
you're going to have black people doing
it to
lie to black people you know you have
that you're going to have asian people
doing it
to lighter asian or darker asian people
you know this this
huge colorism and racism in in india
you know between that what we would
class as one race
they would split into many different
castes
you know you know subhanallah they would
say well these people are lighter
these are you know these people are
darker and you know they've got these
issues within the same race
you know so you it's just something
that's always gonna be there
you know um you know uh there was
also these type of things that happened
uh with the early muslims as well
and it's islam that dictated and
corrected it
it didn't wipe it off off the earth
islam didn't wipe it on
off the earth islam stood as a there as
a test of time to
always compare ourselves to because
every single generation is going to fall
into that mistake
it's not something that can be cured
because
you know it's like it's like um
[Music]
lying and zinna and stealing the you
know
every nation needs to be taught that
these are haram every nation needs to
stay away from it from that
it's not something that gets cured and
then your offspring don't do that
anymore
you know it's a test is we're always
going to have racism
it's never going to go away speaking of
speaking of misguidance when
you were speaking on that bit earlier um
let's go into that because i know a lot
of people that
including muslims they do some weird
stuff back then
back back in like back home countries
india sri lanka pakistan i hear a lot of
stuff about
black magic right and they claim to be
muslim
they claim to be you know but it's like
it's [ __ ] to some degree because they
they think they they have this
you know connection to um allah in some
other way or they use
gin so do you personally have any
experience with any of that or
not really yeah yeah of course i've seen
it throughout the world
um you know different uh almost every
uh almost not every but almost every
country has
um things that have crept into islam
whether it's um innovations
things that are not a part of the
religion it might be small
it might be big um and as you said in in
some
cultures some countries even bigger
problems have happened like
you know people you know um
dealing with gin you know magicians um
motherboards what that's what they
called in in certain parts of africa
magicians
um people um you know
attributing uh attributes of allah to
the creation
whether whether they're dead or alive
you know these things are very common
um and as you said it's by people who
identify as muslim
and as muslims we still we they're still
we still see them as muslim
we we don't do tak fear on on
ignorant people does that make sense
somebody just because somebody may be
doing an act of cover or an act of shirk
we don't uh uh just just say they're not
muslim
and that's not how it works in islam and
we believed that they would have the
you know the excuse of ignorance and
that would that's our job now to give
da'wah to these people
to call them away from that thing of
course if they was to persist in these
evil things
after being taught the truth you know
some scholars
you know may may uh
may actually see them as not muslim you
know but that's not our job
you know as as as just basic muslims to
go around just
calling everyone a non-muslim you know
that's not how it works
you know these things that we do that
are not
good uh or right you know from an
islamic perspective
there's things that every single one of
us do because we're ignorant
because maybe we we don't know um the
evil
in in doing something you know so that's
a lot to guide us
that's why it's important to you know to
try to to do the best
we can um i was watching an episode uh
that you had with ayura you were talking
with musa
and you were going into uh this i forgot
what it was i forgot if
it was like an amulet coin or something
like that that you had um
and when i heard that story i was like
you want to go into that a bit if you're
cool for a lot of people that aren't
really familiar with that
yeah so amulets are things like lucky
charms which
which kind of magicians will will give
you
um sometimes they have quran inside them
but most of the time it's just uh magic
you know
it's gibberish or the spells or his
names of jinn um and and people
in many different muslim countries
throughout many countries in africa
even parts of arabia um in the far east
in in the middle east in
in asia pakistan india these things are
very common
where the muslims wear them
and they seek protection from them
and and this is very dangerous
especially in this day and age because
you know uh a lot of the time it's known
that most of these things
are uh involving shirk and
dealings with the jinn you know um
there's two opinions regarding amulets
you know some of the early scholars
um they did allow amulets um but it had
to be
quran but i personally follow the
opinion it's not permissible
to wear these things i think that we
should recite
the the ayah of the quran like ayatollah
for protection rather than wear it but
you know um you know some people say
well you know these
early scholars allowed amulets okay
maybe they did but the point is that
uh most of the scholars say it's not
permissible
and in this day and age when you know
that
90 or the majority percent of these
amulets
are dealing with shirk you know they
have
um you know they're dealing with gin you
know and and
and most of them are just lies as well
it's it's just a
you know a trickster taking money from
you and giving you
you know an amulet you know most of them
don't even know how to deal with jinn as
well
so it's it's just um you know
allah has given us a protection in the
quran and the son he's told us how to
protect ourself
you know first of all protecting
ourselves with although
and praying our five daily prayers on
time
this is your biggest protection and you
find that most people that where amulets
are not even praying
so you know you're trying to seek
protection
in these uh these things which are
doubtful and and very doubtful
when you know you're not even doing the
basics um
you know your ad car and things like
that so um
you know it's just useless it's
pointless um but these things did
uh i i was aware of these things before
islam
and they were very real you know i mean
i come into contact with people who were
dealing with the jinn before islam
and it was very real you know some of
the things i've seen and
you know it was definitely true and then
you know islam was the only religion
that had an explanation for
jinn you know i believed in gen before
islam
i believe there was this parallel world
but i didn't know how it
how it worked you know and i watched a
lecture by
uh dr bilal phillips and he explained
how the gin get their information
you know um some of them can fly some of
them can take
information um from the summer you know
when that when the
when the information is being delivered
to the angels etc they can steal some of
this information
so the gin sometimes they tell you truth
but they also give you a lot of lies and
they play a lot of tricks
you know so um that lecture was very
influential on me
to understand that islam has an answer
for this supernatural
um thing so yeah
[Music]
have you had experience with these
things before or
i have perhaps yeah what have you
experienced
me yeah i've had two experiences
personally
um one of them was have you heard of
this thing called remote viewing
remote viewing on the on the computer
no it's it's it's basically where
people can see what you're seeing
without being with you
oh no never heard that yeah it sounds i
know it sounds it sounds rubbish
but bear with me there was this guy that
i barely knew
i gave him a i'm like an online coach so
i make like these
workout programs right so i made like an
at-home workout program and
he i think bought uh one copy of it
and that's the last we spoke and then he
hits me up like a year after
i think i told both of you about this
and he hits me up a year after saying
hey man i have some i have a review and
i have some feedback if you want it
i'm just like bro a year later like what
are you on and
i was like okay cool like i'm i'm
interested like give me the feedback
right
and this man starts telling me instead
of my my program he starts telling me
things about me
and i was like i was like i barely know
and even if i knew him i wouldn't have
told him these things but i was like
okay maybe it's a coincidence
he starts telling me more things and i
was just like what like
how do you know all that like we don't
even talk right yeah and i'm just like
okay that's that's kind of interesting
um he's from the uk by the way and again
it was a year later so i was like okay
uh whatever i didn't really
and he's like oh you want to know how i
know these things and i was like
tell me bro and he's like
i'm doing this thing called remote
viewing and i was like what's that
and he's like uh look it up so i go on
my phone i google it
right apparently this is this is things
that people used in like
world war ii there's u.s government
websites saying this is banned
and it is one of the most illegal crimes
that you can commit and i'm like bro why
would this be a crime this makes no
sense
and if the us government knows about it
why is it not mainstream right
and i look a little bit more into it and
it basically it's
when you can see what somebody else is
seeing
through their eyes without being with
them and i was like bro this
sounds like rubbish like and then i i
leave
uh my kitchen and i come back to my room
and he's like oh why'd you leave
and i was just like what do you mean why
that leaves and then i went outside and
he's like oh why are you outside now and
now i'm like
okay that's weird maybe maybe he has uh
you know access to my camera maybe he
hacked my phone i don't know that so
that could be a thing right so
i'm here trying to rationalize what's
going on and
i then turn off my phone i go another
day just doing me
and this man literally told me
everything i did bro yeah
and i'm just like it sounds to me like
he's just dealing with gin
yeah 100 100 so i told rami about the
same thing
romney's just like bro just just don't
even you know so i obviously like
blocked that that
was one encounter the second encounter
was uh i woke up one day
and this is something you never do after
waking up i had some feeling
or some instinct to just check my camera
roll right nobody wakes up
one day people check their phone people
check their messages maybe
but they never check their camera right
so i go to my photos for some reason and
i see
um there was two recordings two video
recordings from a couple hours ago
i went to sleep around one or two a.m
i woke up around 10 a.m and the
recording was from about 4 19 a.m i
still remember the time
it was 4 19 a.m and it was obviously in
my room where my phone
is right so it was dark it was like a 15
second clip
so i watched the whole thing john you're
not going to believe that i didn't find
anything on it
there was no movement there was nothing
so i kind of just you know turned it off
i got up brushed my teeth and i was like
okay it's a video
that means there must be audio too so go
back on my phone i click the
i click the thing on my camera i put up
the sound
you're not going to believe what i heard
um basically
this was back when i lived in my parents
house i live by myself now
but you know in my mom's not my mom's in
my room
my mom kept extra mattresses under my
bed right and she like padded them up
with like these plastics and stuff
what you could hear was something
clawing at the plastics
and trying to rip it right and now i'm
kind of
i'm kind of sketched out so i look under
my bed
and this thing's all messed up it's torn
and i'm like yo
this is weird this was under my bed but
anyway keep listening to the video
and suddenly all you could hear is
whoever or whatever
is tearing the the plastic they stop
and you could hear footsteps as they're
taking off
you literally hear like little footsteps
and now i'm like bro why did they just
like chicken out or whatever so yeah i
called my dad
he's at work and i was like yo did you
wake up last night
and taking the videos from 419 right
and he's like yeah i woke up three times
i woke up once to go to work in the
morning
time before that i woke up around six um
and the time before that i woke up
around 4
20 and the video is from 4 19.
and the time you woke up at 6 i believe
was fajr but
i was like okay when you woke up at 4 20
what did you do
he's like oh i just woke up check my
phone check the time
and i remember seeing 420 and i just
went back to sleep i didn't even like
leave my bed
and i'm thinking bro what if the gin or
whatever that was thought my dad woke up
and just panicked or just maybe they
didn't they thought there was no other
presence and
they sent my dad away maybe they took
off maybe they wanted to harm me
who knows that's crazy it's hella crazy
man and when i tell people they get
goosebumps i'm getting goosebumps but
yeah i guess since then i kinda
i knew that this was very real islam had
an understanding explanation for it so i
started doing some
some research i found these clinical
studies saying that um
mainly for rookia and negative ion
treatment i did some research into that
and
basically using a pink salt lamp one of
those himalayan salt lamps
which release negative ions into the
because gin don't like negative ions
that is a fact many people don't know
about this we talked about this in a
in an episode we did on gin and rokia
and black magic so
um there's clinical studies showing that
gin
that create infertility mental illness
in a lot of people
these cases were only cured through
negative on treatment
right negative ions being released by uh
by
the pink salt lamps right i got one
right behind me and i started using that
every night
let me get that information from how do
you know they don't like that
oh there's uh there's clinical studies
that that they've talked about cases
that have
uh had successful people that were
infertile for one because they believed
that
infertility was caused by jinn they have
uh references from
hadith that i found for that and then
they talk about how
these people have been trying to
conceive for years never successful
right
i even know the chick's name she's a phd
um and
apparently when they did the sorokia
negative ion treatment
like rookia combined with negative ion
treatment they were able to conceive
just like that people that have had uh
anxiety depression bipolar disorder
borderline personality disorder all
caused by gin they believe and then they
do the negative
treatment in nokia they're straight and
my mind is blown
so for me i can't speak on that i do
know these are
like peer-reviewed i guess primary
literature but what i personally had was
i was kind of hopeless my man if you had
something on your camera roll
and you had all these things that i had
you're kind of desperate right
so i didn't really look too much into
these but what i did was i was like okay
this has a this is a reputable article
right i buy myself a himalayan pink salt
lamp
and what i will say is
i could never see any jinn but i could
feel jin
and for me i never knew what jin felt
like
until i felt the presence of them not
there
so all those nights in my room no i
don't know you know
[Music]
is unseen and um even even when it comes
to rookia
a lot of the um techniques in rookia
are not necessarily things that are
clearly documented in the quran and the
sunnah
[Music]
you know apart from you know certain
ayah that i mentioned in the quran and
the sunnah
which are you know known um to be used
specifically as a protector
[Music]
that recommended that to one of the
sahabi
um so um the point is that this certain
ayah that
have been clearly mentioned as as a
protection you know
but a lot of rookia is is kind of
experienced
from from scholars and and different um
you know iraqis people who perform
rookie
[Music]
and and you know suffer i believe that
if you
if you you know
if you're doing what you can in terms of
you know making your show your salies on
time you're reading your other
staying in you know uh away from these
evil things um you know you have a
higher
higher percentage of not being affected
by
evil things and if you're you know in
evil places like nightclubs
or you're not praying your salah you
know these people are more likely to be
affected by
gin but that's not to say that religious
practicing people are not affected by
gin i know
yeah very religious people who are very
good people
from what we know of okay um but they've
been affected by
sihar and jin and these things um
i would just say to put more trust and
the
majority of your trust into the quran
you know the the you know reciting your
what we're told to um you know in the
morning and the evening
you know you might have seen this
fortress of a muslim you have one of
these
yep i do yeah so
um so this you know has all the lists of
different at her
especially that you can make as a
protection before you know you sleep
and and this you'll be fine you know um
yeah no this was something that happened
like two two and a half years ago man
i wasn't even practicing back then i
don't i don't believe
i i i don't necessarily believe that
somebody was seeing through your eyes
um is that something that yeah
you know i believe that it it's a gen
right so the gin
our jinns communicate with each other
every human has a karina a jinn
who is most probably a magician i'm
when i say a magician somebody who's
communicating with the gin
messing around he's a magician okay
so his gin is probably communicating
with your jin
telling him always just gone out of the
room or he's just gone to the garden
you know and that's as much they have
it's not that they
are seeing every single thing that you
do you
probably said yeah you know um
you know he he like he probably told him
your favorite food or
it told him information about you which
there's no way this guy knows and i've
had that myself
i had that in africa where this
particular magician was
telling telling me things that only i
know about myself how does he get
information
because my gin my kareem my companion
who is with me from birth
and he's with me side by side knows
everything about me
he knows my favorite cakes he knows what
every single bit of information about me
so then when he meets the other gin he's
telling him he says yeah
tell him this and he'll make him believe
in you you know
and so this is how people get caught up
with fortune tellers
and and tarot card readers and palm
readers
because the palm reader a lot of them
are fake don't get me wrong a lot of
them are fake
they don't know anything they're just
reading you from a psychological
perspective
well those who do actually know how to
communicate with the gin
it's so simple the gin is telling them
information about you
[Music]
the power reader is like yeah you know
he used to go to this school
and you know uh you know he's just
telling the information
and it looks really complicated but in
reality
it's just a trick from the gym i heard
apparently like
you had an experience with uh with an
amulet coin in in uh
in africa something like that or
yeah you wanna do you wanna tell us a
bit about that yeah i mean before in
islam you know a lot of my friends were
involved in bad things okay you know so
in order to do these bad things you have
to
live and do what they do and they
use these things as a protection you
know a lot of criminals
um who are doing bad things they believe
in these things they
they go to the the marabou they get you
know some sort of
uh spell on them or uh
an amulet which is supposed to protect
you from the police
you know and these type of things and it
happens it actually works you know
because
it boosts you the whole purpose is it
they want
they want to bring you into coffer they
want you to believe
in these things which takes you outside
of islam right
you know you you start believing in this
little amulet is protecting you
then that's kufa right you know so
that's that's the goal of the magician
so you know
maybe when the policeman catches me
you know the jinn scares him or the jinn
tells him leave him let him go
so then it happens and then your iman is
boosted more and more in this amulet
so you going deeper and deeper into
cover and shook
you know so yeah i had experience in
these things
um alhamdulillah allah guides and um
[Music]
what were you saying about everyone has
a gin because there's a woman
yeah i want you to elaborate on that
because before i came to islam maybe
like a year before
i spoke to this woman and
she was on this like new age stuff but
she said
not a gin she referred to it as a demon
we we can both see it as like the same
thing pretty much
and she was saying that like everyone
has uh
a gin for like a better words assigned
to them from birth yes
it's true i mean this is an islamic
concept
we believe everyone has a companion
with them from the jinn creation
you know so this gin will be it's around
you is is
it is you know it's around you if you
know the prophet salallahu salaam his
jinn
became a muslim you know um
so this this kareem is with you
throughout your life and you know in the
cartoons where you see
you've got a devil on one shoulder on
the other
you know the devils whispering bad
things the angels whispering good things
we kind of have that concept in islam
you know where you know we do have
the jinn who are whispering evil things
you know
they whisper us and they give us you
know when you sometimes maybe you have
that very evil thought and you're like
oh zabila
this isn't me this isn't my my thought
this is a whisper
the same way you can have a a a a
a devil or a sheep a companion is a
shaytan from the humans
you can have a friend who is evil he's
also a shaytan
[Music]
you know share tina not only jinn
some thing can be humans you know if you
if you're an evil human you're certain
if you're an evil gender you're sure
thing not all
you know um so you know these
shaytan are whispering to you to do evil
things
and at the same time the angel is
encouraging you
do good things you know um reminding you
um also protecting you um
so yeah this is this is in islam you
know
so can i korean harm us
well when you look at jin in general
uh yeah jin can harm you they can harm
you by whispering to you
making you think bad things
encouraging you to do bad things they
can also physically harm you as well
you know you know they can possess you
they can harm you
i don't know specifically about your
kareem but yeah
well generally junior they can help yeah
of course yeah
we see protection if people didn't harm
us
and they couldn't affect us we would not
need to seek protection from them
you know but when the protection is in
the quran
in reciting them you know
not i wouldn't put all my trust in the
lamp
not all your trust in the lampaki i mean
you know i don't know specifically about
the lamp
but protection is in the quran oh 100
100 percent so yeah that is
why why do we have
a yeah why do we have that
the korean is there to as a test is
everything in life is a test and
and so the korean is there as a test as
well
you know the korean is the korean is
testing us
you know encouraging us to do bad the
same way your
evil friend is testing you telling you
come to the nightclub
you know or do this or do that
your friend is a test you know
so you know the the the point is that we
have to overcome these tests
you know and and how do we overcome them
by
by living the correct way as best we can
according to
islam so um
but this is this is the importance of
having revelation in the first place as
we come back to
revelation you know this is the guidance
from allah this
this quran that is our guidance subhan
allah
you know and and and the teachings of
the prophet salallahu
we have to obey you know obey allah and
his messenger whether we like it or not
you know sometimes we do things that we
we think are good but in fact there's a
lot of harm in it as well
you know so but yeah subhanallah
you know i know a lot of people like
this topic of gin and things like that
but i think people give
this topic too much uh attention
yeah they're not as strong as powerful
as you think
yeah weak when we have the quran when
you recite the quran they're very
terrified of the quran i don't know if
you if you have ever
experienced someone who's possessed
and experienced rookie when when
you know they're the jinn are very weak
there we go
when it comes to the quran have you
experienced it
of course is is
what's happening yeah i mean the quran
it burns them it kills it kills the gin
you know it
it affects them you know it
it really affects the jinn when when
they possess a human
the quran is a is subhanallah you really
see
the the real power of the of the of the
quran
you know it's the words of allah
you know very strong very powerful
you know when allah says it's a
protection it's a protection
you know especially this an ayah that
are used
subhanallah
it's uh it's an interesting topic
[Music]
but you know i want to what about that
was the christians i want to speak about
that
topics of gin they like to feel um
the hairs on the back of their necks
stand up
i have to admit bro you're you're a good
storyteller so kind of like you had me
there
with these
i know you had some stuff to uh to ask
brother john on
i just how would a christian so lead
away with your questions bro
um well i mean i asked the general
question about about dawa to christian
christians but um so give us a sneak
peek of the book what are the do's and
don'ts about dao to christians i know
you mentioned don't say we just
take the bible and accept it but uh what
else is there
yeah i mean i i prefer you know when we
when we're speaking to christians
we have to educate them we have to treat
it as an
education you know i'm just looking here
from a non-muslim perspective
like before islam i knew nothing about
islam
so how am i supposed to come to islam
unless you've educated me about islam
you know iman belief is based on
knowledge
it's not based on jin stories
iman you know your belief that that
feeling of iman
is not based on scary stories he's based
on knowledge
learning about allah learning about his
messenger learning about
the islamic perspective of islam and
musa and ibrahim
and hellfire and paradise and the you
know
all these things that's how we're going
to become a muslim
that's how someone enters islam they
can't enter islam and unless they have a
certain level of knowledge
how can someone become a muslim if they
don't know
that we believe in the absolute oneness
of allah
you know if somebody still believes issa
is the son of allah
or isa has some powers you know
or things like this or you know
they can't become a muslim unless they
have the correct knowledge
so with dawah we have to treat it like
a a a process of education
teaching them all the basics of islam
you know it's not necessarily refuting
them refuting them
refuting their religion yes there's a
time and a place for refuting their
religion
but you don't have to refute
christianity unless they're
trying to defend christianity the
sincere people
they're going to accept everything you
say they're willing to learn about islam
you know nobody had to disprove
christianity to me
because i'd already disproved it myself
i need to i needed to know about islam
so a lot of the taos should be focused
on teaching
uh the christian the
the islamic way the islamic beliefs
so much effort goes into just proving
their belief wrong
rather than telling them what we believe
you know
so do you think it's more feasible to
start with establishing common ground
common grounds one way to get them
interested people who are attached
to their religion you know showing them
who believe in islam and maryam
but i think that the way is to
uh to teach them the islamic perspective
of allah
you know that is absolute oneness the
islamic perspective of prophets and
messengers
they don't have that concept fully
i'm in perspective of revelation
you know the islamic perspective of
judgment day and the and the hereafter
islamic perspective of angels the
islamic perspective of divine decree
these are the six pillars of iman
you know in the hadith of jabril you
know
gibril came and asked what is islam
and the prophet said the five pillars of
islam you know
what is he a man and he mentioned the
six pillars of iman
belief in allah the angels the books the
prophets
the judgment day the divine decree so
these are the core
foundational beliefs that that need to
be
articulated and conveyed um
for for the uh the person who's
interested
um in the correct way as well first of
all we have to have the correct
belief otherwise we're gonna we're gonna
convey the wrong belief
you know yeah that's true so how would
you give that
to a christian i want to i want to ask
you guys
let's start with uh the newest muslim
reaper brother on hell go first uh well
that i do not know the only thing that i
could say
is uh leave by my actions just because
like my knowledge isn't extensive
you know so like if i'm being the best
muslim that i can be
they'll see that and it'll speak louder
than anything i can say right now
allah that's true
um a blend between action and
uh establishing common ground
that's very cool i uh i talked to
brother ajaz
uh once i was supposed to have a debate
but it kind of just
went up in the wind but um debate was a
job
no no not with the jazz no he would he
would he'd probably kill me
but uh uh a debate about christianity
well i mean he couldn't kill me because
we have the same belief but um i asked
him
like what are some arguments and all
this stuff and he told me listen
establishing taheed is is disproving the
trinity so all you need to do is teach
tahit talk about taheed
and then teach it properly and inspire
allah it's
it's very aligned with what you're
saying just teach islam
uh because that's all they really need
and i was like subhan allah you know
so i think what i would do is i would i
would establish
islamically and deductively that god can
only be one
having a son a daughter companions
associates
of allah all that stuff it doesn't even
really make sense uh
deductively from it just kind of deduce
that
um but also from an islamic perspective
um give that
and i think that's essentially how i
would do it i've been trying to stay
away from the bible but
as soon as you said that um you know
people who believe jesus have some kind
of power
you know like like stuff for allah they
shouldn't believe that they're already
like they can't be muslims they believe
that
the first thing that popped my head was
oh in the bible jesus says i have my own
self can do nothing but then i realize
i'm kind of falling in a trap of using
the bible
um and i was gonna ask for your opinion
on that should we just
completely avoid using the bible um
you know what i have a principle for my
own self
right because i think we can um they did
we can use the bible in a very limited
way
um and i think the first way the first
point about
using the bible we have to make it very
clear
that we don't believe in it we don't use
the bible
as an evidence for our own belief
does that make sense so you can use it
to to explain to them what they're
supposed to believe
but using it i believe using it as an
evidence for our own belief is
problematic
for a few reasons and i'll i'll mention
some of the reasons in a moment
but so let me give you an example
because examples
make it more clear so um
[Music]
you mentioned that when jesus says in
the bible
i of my own self can do nothing the
problem with saying that is number one
okay
did jesus actually say that
that makes sense yeah can we prove that
isla is
not from an islamic perspective now
if we go with the apparent meaning of it
that jesus says i can't do anything you
know except what god helps
it doesn't go against islam you know the
apparent meaning of it
doesn't um go against the teachings of
islam does that make sense
like for instance there's some verses
that would go against islam
for instance jesus being called the son
of god
okay of course we can debate on what sun
means
but the concept of son of god anyway
even
as a as a kunya as a nickname does not
fall within the islamic narrative we
don't we'd never call prophets
sons you know so the point is that
if we uh the problem with quoting the
bible
is you could quote it you could quote
that verse to show what they believe
but the problem is muslims fall into the
trap of quoting it as if we believe isa
said that
and we don't even did yeah no
the bible it doesn't we can't trace the
bible back to isla
or musa it has no chain of transmission
it's not in the language of isa and musa
you know um it doesn't claim to be
the kitab allah it doesn't claim to be
the injil yeah okay
it's the new testament it's a collection
of biographies it's not
the book that was given to jesus it's
not that
you know it's not the torah that was
given to moses
okay they label it the torah or they
label parts of the bible the torah
well it's not the torah that was given
to moses it's not the book that allah
gave to musa
the torah that they labeled that the
books that they labeled the torah today
like biographies that's not what allah
gave to musa
so um as i said i think it can be
problematic uh quoting the bible
especially when we're quoting it with
our own tafsir
like you had your own understanding of
what that verse means
i have my own self can do nothing right
number one you're not sure that isa said
that number two
uh you don't you can't be sure what the
tafsir is
what the meaning of it is you know the
christian could argue well yeah
that's jesus couldn't do anything except
with the father
but the father and son are one they have
their own explanation right
yeah um i think there's
certain things historical things we can
mention
you know um but we have to be very
careful
i think number one it has to be
a judo christian tafsir
[Music]
not our own tafsir not an islamic
explanation of the verse
it has to be their explanation right
and um as i said we have to be very
clear from the beginning we don't
believe in it as a
as a text we're simply quoting it
to show you what to to point out and
explain what you believe
you know yeah um
and also i think there's certain things
like from a historical perspective
and a logical perspective we can point
out like where easter says that he has a
god
you know my god and your god this is um
this indicates that asa had a god
you know we don't believe we we're not
confirming issa said that we're not
confirming the bible to be true
we're just pointing out that from their
perspective
jesus says he has a god you know what
does that mean
we should question them more about the
bible than rather give
our own interpretations i'll give you an
example
if you know like there's there's
obviously things that are true in the
bible right
you know like it speaks about asalay
salaam it speaks about moosa
but it doesn't mean that it's from from
allah
you know truth can come from many
different places
you know so when we're speaking to them
ask them what does this mean you know
question them let them get that they'll
get doubts about the book
you know ask them how is this connected
to
issa speak about the lack of
preservation of the scripture
the language of the scripture i think
these things are helpful
but we have to be careful in not
speaking in a way that
makes them think that we actually give
it credibility
you know problematic yeah
yeah it it it makes me think because um
you look at the torah that is found
today
the bible that's found today and the
quran is found today
one thing that you can link through all
three of them
is that musa and isa both
perform miracles now those miracles were
a direct result of
allah right and when a christian says
like oh well
jesus is god because he performed these
miracles it's like well
then what is musa yeah you know
musa perform miracles too is he god
is he is he another god definitely
some some christians i've even heard say
that uh jesus has to be god because
he didn't have a father or something and
i was like if if anyone's
by that account then adam alaihissalam
should have been goddamn
because he didn't even have a mom or dad
yeah right like where do you draw the
line between
inferring things but then kind of taking
actual revelation
yeah these are examples allah uses in
the quran
you know two examples allah used you
know he compared
uh isla islam to adam you know it's just
a miracle
and even even yahya yahya was a miracle
you know the cousin of isa you know
because
his uh his mother was was very old
you know and and it was a miracle that
yahya was even
conceived you know
so you know the story of yahya and isa
is very similar
you know um the the mother of maryam
was making dua you know for a child she
was
she was old um
zakaria and his wife were making dua
for a child you had a sales salaam you
had yahya both of them
were born the angel came to tell
maryam and also tell the mother of yahya
about
you know uh sorry you told zakaria and
that
that uh yahya would come and he said
come the stories are very similar
yeah you know um uh surah maryam speaks
about that
you know first he speaks about zakaria
and
you know and again you know the stories
are very similar
anyone that is currently watching that's
christian and has made it this far
uh before we close out this episode do
you have any words of advice
to point them in the right direction
yeah i would just encourage them to
to learn about islam you know learn the
basics of islam
you know learn what the beliefs are of a
muslim
maybe read the quran in an english
translation
if you if you have it and learn you know
try and learn more about islam and just
be honest with yourself
you know you sincere and you want to
find the true religion
you know put your head on the ground
right and ask the creator to guide you
you know when you're alone in your
bedroom
lay at night put your head on the floor
and ask the creator to guide you if
you're sincere
and if islam is the way accept it when
it come when it becomes clear to you
don't delay it except islam you know
don't
don't lie to yourself you know just
accept him
you know that that's the thing
[Music]
mommy i think uh i got my answer
it's been honestly an amazing episode
may allah bless you and reward you for
all the work you do
to all the viewers who made it this far
uh comment hashtag
because yeah yeah is john in english
subhanallah
um i think it's fitting so with that
being said subhanallah
follow up keep up with their brother
john on his youtube on socials and wait
for his book to come out
tawa to christians insha allah to allah
any last words brother john
no thanks for having me on it's nice to
meet you you too
it's been a close all right check out
young smokes and check out
uh john fontaine channel as well link in
the description
yes all right with that being said
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hmm